my name is Bettina Warburg I'm a
researcher of transformative
technologies and co-founder of animal
ventures today I've been challenged to
explain one concept at five levels of
increasing complexity my topic is
blockchain technology blockchain is a
new network and it's going to help us
decentralize trade allowing us to do a
lot of our transactions much more
peer-to-peer directly and lower our use
of intermediaries like companies or
banks maybe I think today everyone can
leave understanding something about
blockchain at some level do you know
what we're gonna talk about today it's
called blockchain with black teen that's
a really good question
it's actually a way that we can trade do
you know what trade is it's what is when
you take turn your sign that's when you
give up most of what you want right when
you give up most of what you want well
sometimes that definitely happens for
sure what if I told you that there's a
kind of technology that I work on that
means you could trade with any kid all
over the world yeah I could train with
any kid I would trade well I would trace
children they don't like you much that's
probably a good idea maybe somebody else
likes it more than you do so normally
when people trade they have to go to the
store or they have to know the person so
that they can get what they asked for
with blockchain you can make that exact
same trade but you don't need the store
and you don't even necessarily need to
know the other person
so Ian do you know what blockchain is no
have you ever traded or sold anything
actually I'm selling my computer on eBay
right now that's amazing what made you
decide to trade on eBay um well I mean
I've heard of it and I trust it a lot
because there's they have like all their
guarantees so I I know that I'm gonna
get money and the person is gonna get
what they want so what if I told you
that blockchain technology is basically
a tool where you can do the exact same
thing but it goes to you and I directly
you wouldn't need an eBay or a brand in
between that's cool and there's a lot of
those kinds of middlemen
in our society today right we have a lot
of banks we have a lot of companies that
sort of help us make sure that our
trades happen but if we could guarantee
the same trade using technology as sort
of like a technological trust then we
wouldn't really need all those middlemen
in between so how does it work it's
basically a network of computers that
all have the same history of
transactions and so instead of sort of
there being one company with one
database that holds all the information
the same sort of list is held by all
these different people like you could
have it on your computer and then it
gets validated by everyone and basically
that turns into the next part of the
list so it's sort of constantly updating
itself so like how do you make sure that
it's secure so it uses cryptography and
that helps it basically encode all of
the transactions so you can't really see
exactly what happened but you know it
happened because it's like a marker so
you could kind of like I don't know say
trade you trade apples but you would
just see like random letters yeah where
it's saying I wouldn't be able to like
track it exactly that's cool so it's
kind of this like really big ledger or
accounting system from all sorts of
things that get traded but instead of
being owned by one company it's owned by
everybody that's cool yeah we're gonna
talk about blockchain technology have
you heard of boxing
I've heard of the words blockchain but
I'm not sure I know what it is so when
we were much smaller societies you and I
could trade in our community pretty
easily but as the distance in our trade
grew we ended up inventing institutions
right if you use uber or you use Airbnb
or you use Amazon even these are just
digital marketplaces and platforms that
help us facilitate an exchange of value
mm-hmm but today we actually have a
technology that allows us to trade
one-to-one but at scale and it's called
blockchain technology there is some kind
of interface for it you could have an
app or you could use your computer to do
it but instead of there being a company
in the middle or what's helping you make
that transaction is a bunch of software
code and so it's being run by all of
these different computers that have like
a node so they're all running the same
software and guaranteeing your
transactions as they happen I mean I
would assume this technology is taking
away business or activity from these
middlemen in some cases yeah it is and a
lot of people in the financial industry
in particular are looking at it from the
banking side of how do we use this
technology to trade things like Bitcoin
or other tokens that are easier to use
instead of today's currency you know a
lot of people think about blockchain as
Bitcoin because it's sort of in the news
a lot and it's this new cryptocurrency
and it's kind of exciting but we're
actually seeing a lot more use cases for
blockchain that aren't around the
currency side they're more around how do
you take any asset and be able to trade
that using the same technology is there
a mechanism for verifying that person a
is a legitimate seller or producer of
the item
so today a lot of people are working on
how to create identity structures that
leverage blockchain and one of the tools
for doing that is being able to
cryptographically assign for a given
attribute so your government could sign
that you have a u.s. passport or a
university could sign that you are a
currently enrolled student and you could
then dole out that information and
control it yourself and be able to show
people those certifications on an
as-needed basis so today we're gonna
talk about blockchain technology okay
have you ever heard of blockchain I have
whenever we have a transaction and let's
say I buy something from you this
information gets logged and it gets
verified by a third person or third
party and then if like all this
information verified and it all matches
right the transaction goes through
without any intermediary basically right
then it gets stored and when we make
further transactions this information is
ready and better that's in in the ledger
yeah that's exactly right
and you can append it you can sort of
add new information that's more current
but you can't actually go erase anything
absolutely right the way the technology
is changing nothing is gonna be like it
used to be and there's no like firm and
then the buyer and the seller and it's
basically will have to rewrite a lot of
rules in economics as well for sure a
lot of the assumptions won't hold true
same with who are the who are the actors
it's not just people anymore it's
machines absolutely we're gonna have to
create entire new concepts of how they
do trade and how they work with us -
what kind of barriers or roadblocks
would you imagine are gonna happen in
the blockchain space so at least going
there we we talk about Bitcoin there are
some trust issues have been some hacks
and so there's obviously a need to work
on on trust and feeling that it's it's a
safe technology yeah one of the problems
that Bitcoin is faced is bitcoins
getting stolen or lost but a lot of that
actually comes from people trying to
resent relize coin in different way
making themselves actually a pretty easy
target absolutely so education will be a
big part before we actually can use the
technology in a wide sense yeah to
actually transition into the mainstream
and make it useful for average people to
use we're going to need to make sure we
have a lot more education a lot more
standards and probably work with a lot
of enterprises to create sort of the
user experience around this being a
technology that is safe and usable and
understandable what is the current state
of blockchain in your understanding
what's gonna have to happen next the
current state is in this the research
state and it's being developed to be
applied in many many areas it might be
used almost everywhere - we're like we
won't even imagine how we live without
it but I'm not sure where it's gonna go
I mean no one really knows right well we
have a lot of public box chains like we
have Bitcoin we have the etherium
Network NXT but a lot of companies and
consortiums are getting together to
build private blockchains so ones that
are more closed off at first and then
they evolved into a public network when
people feel comfortable using it and
some are also proof of concepts out in
the real world projects in energy and in
pharmaceuticals and in retail and lots
of different fields are starting
experiments and we'll see in the next
few years how all of those interact and
what we learn about the best use cases
for blockchain and what it means for
trade so tell me your version of a
technical definition of blockchain a
technical definition of blockchain is
that it is a persistent transparent
public append-only ledger so it is a
system that you can add data to and not
change previous data within it it does
this through a mechanism for creating
consensus between scattered or
distributed parties that do not need to
trust each other but just need to trust
the mechanism by which their consensus
has arrived at
in the case of blockchain they realize
on some form of challenge such that no
one actor on the network is able to
solve this challenge consistently more
than everyone else on the network yes
yeah it randomizes the process and in
theory ensures that no one can force the
blockchain to accept a particular entry
onto the ledger that others disagree
with one that relies on the mechanism
for a peer-to-peer network that can
maintain updates to the ledger and then
verify those updates in such a way that
it is impossible to defraud and
impossible to alter after the fact do
you see it as defining a new discipline
of kinds or where where are we gonna see
blockchain emerge in the real world
first I mean just so like as an example
one thing that I think about a lot in
terms of possible blockchain
applications is electricity right the
next generation of distributed smart
grid technology effectively because
working on yes yeah yeah exactly
and it's this very fruitful area of
research and you can find yourself
looking like 20 years out right where
you have an enormous number like of
electric cars you have all of these
batteries like that's essentially a
distributed peak load power grid right
like the cars are getting plugged in and
unplugged at different times if you have
a mechanism that is able to
automatically and autonomously be
distributing power based on batteries
that are scattered throughout the grid
that are being used for other purposes
their owners don't even necessarily need
to be aware you begin to have something
that looks like a much more viable
society that still has a lot of
electricity needs but is able to base
that much more on renewables is able to
make up the difference during peak load
periods or during differences in weather
that is able to have power much closer
to where it's needed rather than having
to be distributed over great distances
like that's something that would be an
enormous ly hard problem to solve and
it's not that the blockchain makes it
easy but it makes it possible a lot of
people are seeing watching the news and
maybe seeing a lot of sort of initial
coin offerings this sort of monetization
opportunities
excited about it now some of that
excitement is is real and should be you
know encouraged but some of it is also
hype how do you feel about the hype
cycle around blockchain today I'm glad
you mentioned initial coin offerings
because for me those really exemplified
the sort of that the problem that we're
having at this exact moment they are a
an idea with enormous potential
significance down the road
however the promise of the initial coin
offering has been kind of hijacked into
this string of like basically pump and
dump scams or sort of desperate gold
rush schemes the faster that we can we
can shift from this this fantasy that it
is going to make you rich in a sort of
you know 1920s tulip bubble kind of way
is is that is the sooner that we can get
into people honestly and I mean this
like with all the hope in the world
people being disappointed in blockchains
like oh I didn't get rich it's just
being used now to make it easier to
transact goods and services safely
across borders this is an exciting at
all and then we'll see that like become
part of the everyday infrastructure of
the world in a way that I think will be
very significant but I think it is now
almost every aspect of it that's
connected with the concept of money is
wildly overhyped and people get a lot of
excitement around it yes they're waiting
for the world to change yeah because
we've had a lot of PR a lot of proof of
concept but yeah truthfully this is more
like a science yes it will develop it
will take five years it will take ten
years that kind of time is necessary one
of the areas that brought me to supply
chain research is the fact that we're
we're not just gonna see blockchain
emerge we're gonna see artificial
intelligence continue to evolve we're
gonna see connected devices and this
sort of growing internet of things
machinery that can do a lot more and
have a wallet and transact on their own
and so I actually think a lot of where
blockchain and other technologies are
headed is this interesting synergy that
will help us elevate the kinds of
institutions we've used in the past
gobbled together yeah to create that
identifiable verifiable trust
and one of the most interesting ideas to
me that came out of the currency side of
the blockchain project was the notion
around like coloring coins right assign
properties to a particular coin and in
particular to assign those properties in
ways that would allow you to do things
like bring in the graph of previous
transactions you know this is sort of an
obvious application for this which is
something that would look a little bit
like an extreme version of like a
boycott divestment and sanctions kind of
approach right a model where it's sort
of like I will not touch money my wallet
will automatically not touch money that
has been exchanged with the following as
a sort of very extreme way of cutting
those things out but there's also ways
in which I think that could be applied
to to clearing out the entire logistics
process of many kinds of bad actors
about trying to make a supply chain
better in some ways realize a lot on
whose version of better that is and
exactly kind of what gets qualified but
also how that is quantified within say
some kind of like smart contract system
there's multiple ways that I could see
this backfiring and one is the ways in
which that is implemented for example
leaving certain kinds of bad behavior
untouched or unanalyzed or one that
feels even more dire to me in some ways
is creating an extremely inflexible
conte like because human contracts legal
contracts are actually very flexible
like there's a lot of kind of room to
negotiate yeah but we we already have
real-world versions of some of these
nightmare scenarios right where like
your kid has a medical emergency and you
can't unlock your car because you're two
days behind on payments for it and so
the car system will no longer respond to
the app mechanism that you're supposed
to be able to use to drive it sort of
rigidity
yes structures that maybe don't
accommodate real-life scenarios very
well as you have been talking one of the
things that keeps coming up is that we
tend to hold novel technologies to an
unrealistically high standard in terms
of what they are supposed to deliver
rather than comparing them to actually
existing systems where we can begin to
see the possibility that even like a
slight incremental improvement would
still be an enormous game the system we
have today is also broken it's it's hard
to compare it to some perfect future
just like we compare you know autonomous
vehicles to this very high standard
yeah because machines are doing it
should be perfect right there should be
zero car - yes and yeah when you say
well there's hundreds of thousands
millions of you know car deaths on the
road due to human error today I think
we're in a similar place we're going to
see problems with this technology and we
are going to need to develop multiple
kinds of standards that also have some
flexibility but it's it's going to also
be a version a system that allows us to
fix some of the things that are broken
today blockchain may sound complicated
but at its core it's just another tool
for humans and eventually robots and
other kinds of identities to trade at
scale and make that trade more
decentralized and it's part of our
future so it's important that people
have these kinds of conversations and
start to learn about it